please welcome the prime minister of
Canada the right honorable Justin
Trudeau and the prime minister of
Ukraine his Excellency Denis schmichael
the first signing is the bilateral
Canada Ukraine youth Mobility agreement
the signatory for Canada is The
Honorable Melanie Jolie Minister of
Foreign Affairs and for Ukraine Her
Excellency Julia kovaliv Ambassador
extraordinary and planet potentiary of
Ukraine to Canada
Canada and Ukraine have enjoyed a close
relationship
Canada became the first Western country
to recognize Ukraine's Independence on
December 2nd 1991.
our bilateral relationship is
strengthened by warm people-to-people
ties rooted in the Ukrainian Canadian
community of 1.4 million people
prime minister Trudeau visited cave on
May 8 2022.
along with the Deputy Prime Minister
Christie Freeland and the Minister of
Foreign Affairs Melanie Jolie to Mark
the reopening of the Canadian embassy in
Ukraine
de Prelude
Canada foreign
real
Independence
this is prime minister's first official
visit to Canada his visit marks a new
chapter in the historic partnership
between our two countries
the second document to be signed
is the joint declaration by the
governments of Canada and Ukraine on the
modernization of the Canada Ukraine Free
Trade Agreement
Ukraine
the signature Canada is
the original Free Trade Agreement
brought benefits to both our countries
the modernization will allow us to
further deepen our bilateral commercial
relations for the long term
thank you this concludes the official
signing ceremony
oh
[Applause]
puzzle to the mount no reconnaissance is
for more than a year now the people of
Ukraine have been heroically resisting
Putin's barbaric invasion
the very young and the very old
remaining Resolute and defiant
as the air raid sirens ring out
civilian recruits and battle-hardened
soldiers
women and men in sustained and brutal
combat
and political leaders who like the
remarkable people they represent
could not have been prepared for the
hand history dealt them
but who have rallied the world with
their resolve
ukrainians have been fighting for their
country
for their sovereignty and for the future
of Ukraine
but in mariopol and in and in the
freezing muddy trenches all across
Ukraine they have also been fighting our
fight
the fight for democracy
is
foreign
[Music]
military
prime minister shmihal and I speak often
and when we do I often reflect on the
fact
that I talked to him in my office in
Ottawa or in my home here in Toronto
but while I'm doing that from the
comfort and safety of Canada I know that
the Miss is in Ukraine leading a nation
at War
Dennis was in Ukraine in cave on that
terrifying night in that now famous
video when president zielinski said
I am here
we are here
yatut
Dennis has become a friend
and he has also become an inspiration to
me
just as I know all Canadians are
inspired by the remarkably brave people
of Ukraine
it was an honor for me and my family to
host in this at my home here in Toronto
last night and to welcome him to Canada
is
na
foreign
and so Dennis I want to thank you very
sincerely for your leadership
for your courage and for your friendship
I am so grateful to you
Canada is grateful to you
and democracy is grateful to you
now we have two prime ministers here and
very early in the war
when most in the west thought cave was
sure to fall
prime minister Trudeau said to me
that he believed Ukraine would resist
and that resistance would make Ukraine
stronger
our prime minister in those very early
days
compared to the battle for kuf to the
Blitz
and he predicted that the Ukrainian
people would rally and unite in the face
of the challenge
just as the British people did
and our prime minister was of course
right you did
our government has been United in our
support for Ukraine because we know that
this fight
the fight for democracy is Canada's
fight too
that belief and resolve comes directly
from our prime minister
so I will now with very great pleasure
turn it over to prime minister Trudeau
and to a man to whom democracy owes a
very great deal the prime minister of
Ukraine yeah
[Applause]
I want to recognize the ministers
Minister Julie Minister Freeland thank
you for your words Minister Anand great
to see you as well as a number of our
strong MPS with great Ukrainian
communities Julie zerowitz arifirani
James Maloney of course Yvonne Baker
good to see you Alexandra president of
the uh you uh Ukrainian Canadian
Congress Ambassador and other dear
friends
foreign
for more than a year now Canada has been
helping ukrainians defend themselves by
sending military assistance including
tanks and armored vehicles ammunition
weapons and other equipment today we're
announcing we'll be sending even more
weapons
sourced from Colt Canada we'll be
sending 21
000 assault rifles 38 machine guns and
over 2.4 million rounds of ammunitions
this will help the Armed Forces of
Ukraine continue to defend their freedom
and fight for Ukraine's territorial
integrity
something prime minister shmihal and I
discussed today was also the financial
situation of his country and the efforts
to rebuild Ukraine to support essential
services including pension payments
purchasing Fuel and restoring damage to
energy infrastructure Canada has now
dispersed a 2.4 billion dollar loan
announced in our budget 2023.
contribute
is situations
[Music]
another thing that will continue to
bring our two countries closer is trade
that's why I was so glad to sit down
with Denny Dennis and sign a joint
Declaration on the conclusion of
negotiations for the modernization of
the Canada Ukraine Free Trade Agreement
it is a
comprehensive and very very strong
agreement that I know will be a model
for the kind of strong engagement that
Ukraine can and will have not just with
Canada but around the world as well and
we're privileged to be once again an
early friend on that we're both deeply
committed to implement it as soon as
possible it'll strengthen our trade ties
and help support Ukraine's economic
recovery not just with Canada but with
the world
Canada has a lot to offer whether it's
skilled workers technological expertise
or natural resources I know that during
prime minister shmihal's visit the
Saskatoon based company chemical signed
a major Supply contract with energo atom
in Ukraine building on their partnership
agreement
camaco will provide the necessary
uranium to meet you clear
Ukraine's nuclear fuel needs until 2035
which will help Ukraine keep the lights
on while creating and supporting good
middle-class jobs here in Canada
social
to maintain the pressure on the Russian
regime we're announcing new sanctions on
14 Russian individuals and 34 entities
including security targets linked to the
Wagner group in addition to further put
in a pressure to further pressure
Putin's enablers in Belarus we're
announcing additional sanctions on nine
entities related to the Belarusian
financial sector
Dennis thank you again for your visit my
friend Canada will continue to be
steadfast in our support of Ukraine as
you defend yourselves heroically against
you putrins brutal barbaric invasion
the courage of ukrainians is heroic
but as you well know than if you are
standing up for more than just
the values and the principles that
ukrainians hold dear you are standing up
for the values and principles that
underpin all of our freedoms and all of
our democracies and it is an
extraordinary pleasure and privilege to
be able to stand with you right now as
we have for many years as we will long
into the future
Canadians stand with you and always will
thank you everyone I'm now very happy to
pass it over to my friend and Canada's
friend
prime minister shmihal Denis
[Applause]
through he Justin
is
the Premier Minister question
foreign
urado
the narodo Canada
is
foreign
strategy
Russia is
foreign
activity
sovereign
level
s
finances
foreign
the only thing necessary for the dream
of evil is for good men to do nothing
foreign
Canada
is the
besties
foreign
[Applause]
first question is to Global over to you
the entire board and the CEO of the
foundation resigned this morning they
cited the recent politization of their
work are you concerned about the
long-term stability of the organization
and that the Fallout from allegations of
foreign interference is extending beyond
your government
as you well know the Trudeau Foundation
is a a foundation with which I have
absolutely no intersection it was
established to promote knowledge and
academic research into the humanities
following the death of my father and has
had an extraordinary impact on academic
institutions and on you know brilliant
Canadians it is a shame to see the level
of toxicity and political polarization
that is going on in our country these
days but I am certain that the Trudeau
foundation will be able to continue to
ensure that research into the social
studies and Humanities at the highest
levels across Canadian academic
institutions continues for many years to
come
second question is to Forum TV over to
you
good afternoon Mr Trudeau and Mr Ishmael
is
foreign
thank you very much
thank you so much
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
um good afternoon
the Canadian president my question is
for prime minister Trudeau leaked U.S
documents suggest that Ukraine's air
defenses in a previous situation right
now you have already committed to
providing one anti-air missile system to
Ukraine is there anything else Canada
will or can do to improve Canada
Ukraine's defense defense systems and do
you have any comments on the leaks in
general
we will continue to support Ukraine with
everything needed for as long as
necessary we stand with Ukraine and we
always will Canadians have been
absolutely
here in Canada but
they're
have been so many uh strong and
impactful members of the Ukrainian
Canadian community over the past decades
that
I think as Vladimir Putin was surprised
at the strength of ukrainians Defending
themselves in those first days of the
war people around the world were
surprised to discover how courageous and
strong and Valiant ukrainians were
Canadians were not so surprised because
we have had the privilege of knowing
ukrainians Among Us for many many many
decades and we know the kind of strength
and resilience you have
the support we will continue to deliver
military economic humanitarian
trade support commercial support working
with grains working as friends on
building a prosperous future for
ourselves and for those who share our
values around the world will continue we
will always step up and I have no conf
no doubt in my mind I have full
confidence that Ukraine will prevail
next question
hi Adrian Gabriel CTV national news a
question for you prime minister Trudeau
I've been speaking with retired Canadian
military who are in Ukraine helping
train Ukrainian Fighters as well as
International retired military they put
together a report that details and
alleges that unfortunately ukrainians
command structure military structure is
still operating in a Soviet era they're
not using NATO training and they say
that it's costing lives it's costing
resources and it's prolonging the war as
Canadians and our government give
billions of dollars to Ukraine is that a
concern for you
um I actually disagree with that report
uh in in how you've characterized it one
of the reasons uh the Ukrainian military
has been able to stand so effectively
against the Russian invasion this past
year has been because countries like
Canada and others have been there for
many years here Canada showed up in
about 2015 with operation unifier to
help train the Ukrainian Defense Force
and we have now trained over 35
members of Ukraine's military and that
has made a extraordinary impact in their
ability to execute on some very
sophisticated military Maneuvers and
been incredibly successful and continue
to be to be so and will continue to be
so uh obviously the much of the
equipment they have is Soviet era which
is why we are so active in delivering
some of the more modern West uh
technologies that we have but I would
not for a second hesitate in
characterizing the
abilities and the approach of the
Ukrainian military forces and the
volunteers and those who serve as being
exceptional and one of the reasons why
we are still
um
seeing such strength from Ukraine and
ukrainians well over a year into what
was supposed to be you know a couple of
weeks of of Russian overwhelming
ukraines Putin miscalculated and it is
to the world's benefit that Ukraine is
as strong as it is
let me add two words the Prime Minister
thank you so much so I should note that
this training missions and unifier is
crucially important for ukrainians and
uh I should repeat that more than 35
000 and we ask for continuation of these
trainings for our soldiers it's
crucially important now especially now
when our army is fighting with Russian
according to the NATO standards by NATO
Weaponry
in NATO style I should note that Russian
army is soviet-style Army and never
small Soviet Army will win big Soviet
Army so the only possibility to win this
war to have very strong NATO
standardized standardized
Army in Ukraine and we actually realize
this strategy and our army now is
absolutely created according to the NATO
standards use NATO weaponry and I should
emphasize that our army our society is
absolutely encouraged to go into ahead
liberate our land we are tired it's
naturally because we fight more than one
year with a second so named second army
in the world but we are not exhausted we
are not fatigue we have encouraged to go
into our head and support of our
partners support of government of Canada
prime minister his team is fulfilled Us
by this
feeling and we are sure that we will win
this war all together thank you one
quick follow-up for prime minister
Trudeau prime minister Trudeau are you
willing to stay publicly to Canadians
that Canada is now at a pro in a proxy
war with Russia if you can give us a yes
or no answer and a brief
reasoning why or why not
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
upended 80 years
of Peace stability and security around
the world one of the most prosperous
eras the world has ever known we have
all benefit benefited from that
immeasurably everywhere around the world
Russia's decision
to end
that piece to violate
the U.N
Charter to overturn international law to
arbitrarily choose to redraw lines on a
map
is of course of deep concern to Canada
in regards to our friends in Ukraine
but should be of real concern to
everyone around the world
everywhere around the world there are a
uthoritarian dictators looking at
Vladimir Putin
curious to see if he will succeed
because everywhere around the world
there are neighbors with larger armies
than the country beside them saying Oh
wouldn't it be nice to redraw the map
wouldn't it be nice to be able to invade
and benefit from that and get a few more
resources or or bring in uh you know
people who speak the same language
this choice that Canada has to stand
unequivocally with Ukraine is yes a
course about the Deep friendship and the
the personal and family and and
demographic ties that we've had with
Ukraine for over a century
but it is also about the right thing to
do
right now Ukraine is yes fighting for
its territorial Integrity its right to
determine its own future and that is
very important and we'll be there for
that
but it's also fighting for the values
and the principles
that underpin all of our democracies all
of the stability and freedom that we've
been able to build in international law
over the past years
that's why Canada stands unequivocally
with Ukraine that's why we will continue
to do everything necessary to ensure
that Ukraine prevails
[Applause]
can I first question is for uh the
Ukrainian prime minister uh what do you
most
urgently need from Canada in terms of
heavy military weaponry weaponry and
does your list include fighter jets
thank you so much for your question we
discuss all urgent needs today was prime
minister and his team first of all we
are preparing for our counter offensive
we need more ammunition we need more
Weaponry we need more military equipment
we discuss all the details I can explain
this publicly but Canada Supply and
support us in supplying many military
equipment and ammunition together with
other allies and our partners the second
issue was sanction support so the next
packages of sanctions on the
personalities Russian persons and their
Industries and in details I explain and
describe why should we Implement
functions on nuclear sphere of Russia
and nuclear industry because of their
nuclear blackmailing all over the world
and European continent we also discuss
other steps about confusion station of
Frozen Russian assets and Canada here is
again number one in sense of creating of
presidents for a confiscation of frozen
assets of Russian oligarchs so all of
these issues are crucially important for
Ukraine now and during this tough times
for Ukraine yeah
follow-up question about the leaks of
classified documents do you think there
will be an impact on operations in
Ukraine
and could you confirm that there have
been incidents affecting our gas
pipelines
answer
well we know that we will continue to
work with our partners throughout the
world to defend Ukraine
to ensure that Ukraine can
stand strong against Russia
and that Russia does not manage to
realign the global order in its favor
nor determine the future of the
Ukrainian people that's why we'll be
there for them
with regard to the cyber attacks you're
referring to
against Canadian gas infrastructure
I can confirm
that no physical harm was caused to
these pieces of Canadian infrastructure
confirm
in regards to the reports of cyber
attacks against Canadian energy
infrastructure
um
I can confirm that there was no physical
damage to any Canadian energy
infrastructure following cyber attacks
next question
my name is Yuri klufas I'm reporting for
contact Ukrainian TV network it's great
to see both countries on the same stage
after all we have the same great
neighbor
Ukraine is experiencing an invasion in a
war most Canadians may not know it but
we're having a similar invasion in the
North Pole which we'll learn about very
soon the
both both of you have mentioned
democracy democratic values and the
greatest threat it seems war or no war
to the world of democracy is Soviet
disinformation and or Russian
disinformation and hacking Soviet
because everything continues on in the
same way the question two
prime minister
what is Ukraine doing in terms of
countering this Russian disinformation
and to prime minister Trudeau maybe on a
lighter note your website has been down
today is that due to Russian hacking
foreign
I should
emphasize that Ukraine for the last
nine years in in war was Russia and it
was not only military war in military
sense it was
a hybrid War which include all kinds of
aggression
hybrid aggression in sense of Migrant
influences on the European Union and on
the Ukraine cyber influences this
information influences propaganda
influences and or energy blackmailing of
Ukraine and European Union so during the
last nine years we were under strong and
very
strong pressure of Russia by the hybrid
methods of attack on Ukrainian
infrastructure Society what we have
implemented in Ukraine first of all we
create all the infrastructure to
deter Russian propaganda and Russian
influences hybrid influences on
Ukrainian Society we closed uh all their
channels for this propaganda in this
information our secret Services works
for the last years we work closely with
intelligence of European Union United
States Canada and we create very strong
cyber security centers in Ukraine
anti-propaganda and anti-disinformation
Center in Ukraine we work closely with
our European partners and share this
experience great European experience
with our partners and especially in the
Cyber sphere in the cyber security
because during this nine years Russia
many thousand times attacked Ukrainian
infrastructure civilian energy
infrastructure by cyber attacks and
during this war we have hundreds and
thousands cyber attacks on our
infrastructure and we may share this
experience we do it we like we Implement
all of this practice and methods and
actually this is very practical issue
and methods so first of all I think that
our colleagues should take a look and
close Russian propaganda and
disinformational channels it's very
important step to stop this this
information but they also use other
hybrid methods and you may see it during
this war all around the world because
they try to realize this in Ukraine 10
years ago but now they they have very
good practice and they share it on the
all countries on the all Partners we
should be very United very United don't
believe any their special psychological
informational operations and to go to
the Victory and to go to stop this
Russian propaganda in this information
thank you so much
um as you know it's not uncommon for
Russian hackers to Target countries as
they are showing their steadfast support
for Ukraine as they're welcoming
Ukrainian
delegations or leadership to visit so
the timing isn't surprising
but in case anyone was wondering uh
Russia being able to bring down an
official government of Canada web page
for a few hours is in no way going to
dissuade us from our uh un uh unshakable
support of Ukraine
uh
come uh
as people probably know
It Is by no means rare to see Russian
cyber attacks targeting countries that
are showing their support to Ukraine
particularly at times
when a high-level political delegation
like this one is visiting but let me be
very clear
the fact that unofficial government of
Canada website was down just for a few
hours that will not in any way deter us
from our present and unshakable support
for Ukraine as it faces
Russia's attack last question and
follow-up
um my first question is for prime
minister Trudeau the mass casualty
commission has made recommendations to
address the issue of intimate partner
violence in Canada are you considering
taking up their recommendations
including appointing a national office
that tackles gender-based violence and a
National Registry of ipv event offenders
the mass casualty commission following
the worst ever
Mass killing in Canadian history of
three years ago in and around Puerto
pick Nova Scotia
the commission did extraordinary work
um 3 000 Pages worth of
research reflection and recommendations
we are taking the time to look very very
carefully at all those recommendations
and I can tell you we will be talking
soon about how we will be moving forward
including on some very very strong
recommendations
combating intimate partner violence
Canada has for the past number of years
move forward with a very strong
gender-based violence strategy but there
is always more to do and that's exactly
what we will continue to look at
including drawing on some of those
excellent recommendations
in regards to the CEO and the board of
directors resigning from the Trudeau
Foundation given that politicize uh
given that they cited politicization
will you continue to appoint people
connected to the foundation to do work
for your government
foreign
those people
who are trying to
get short-term political gain by
increasing polarization and partisanship
in this country by launching completely
unfounded and ungrounded attacks against
Charities or foundations
um
must not succeed
Canada is a place where
we support
good works of all different types
and we need to continue to do that
I am I have no doubt
that the Trudeau Foundation like
foundations and Charities that
conservative politicians have attacked
in the past will continue to do the
excellent work that it will do but as
I've said many times it's a foundation
in my father's name that I have no
director in direct connection with
okay
I have no doubt that despite the attacks
of conservative politicians that have
been going on for years now
on the matter of charitable
organizations and Foundations
and attacks on people who are getting
involved to improve their communities
and Country in a non-partisan fashion
or rather these people will continue to
do their work despite the attacks
the attacks of politicians who want to
make our public debate more toxic
increase the level of polarization
especially in the political Arena
despite all this good people will
continue to work hard
in order to improve the country
and will not be affected by people who
are simply looking to score short-term
political points at the expense of
individuals and organizations that are
serving their country in the common good
as you know the Trudeau Foundation was
named after my father after his death
in order to advance research in social
sciences
I have no direct or indirect connection
with that Foundation but I know that
they will continue to do excellent work
to advance important debates in this
area
like you did
[Applause]